he is the chairman of the Alliance of
American football and also the principal
owner and governor of the bunch of jerks
to play hockey in Carolina he's none
other than Carolina Hurricanes owner Tom
Donahue it's easy tom hey good to see
you thanks for having I figured that's
the I use the Dom the Don Cherry term
for your team's not very nice what's
that all about huh I don't know well I
mean your team is it's interesting
before we get to the AAF by the way
thank you for joining your on the show
appreciate that's great said that that
you know the the celebration
conversation that we've been having in
the NFL for years is now even gonna be
coming up again from the competition
committee because some coaches think
that the on-field celebration after
interceptions by the defenders all get
together and take a mock picture
whatever is too much it's now arrived in
the National Hockey League thanks to
your team with the storm surge after
your your wins plural a late we've had a
few so I assume you you love this sort
of thing right I love it I think you
know when when I bought the team it was
Carolina Hurricanes first of all people
think they're in Charlotte or in Raleigh
right and and it wasn't probably the
highest best known brand and you know we
wanted to change that and my only
conversation with the players is you
know if you create energy and excitement
and connect with the fans more people
watching that should help you to write
because we want them to be a success
we'll make as much money as they can and
then they came up with this and it's
been who came up with the players or the
coach or the players no one will tell me
I didn't know come on you're in charge
they're trying to they're trying to give
you plausible deniability up in the I
don't know I'm concerned because I
didn't know I we won a game I started
walking downstairs
and then I heard they did it and you
know what's happened since it's been we
spent a lot of time after we bought the
team trying to gain traction a marketing
perspective entertainment perspective
and the best idea has been this one that
they came up with and I had nothing to
do which is again after after a win they
started I guess the hockey version of
the Vikings skull change right by
pounding their sticks on the ice with
their hands I think it's above their
heads
when they do something you know it
started off jumping in the wall jumping
into the boards and then since then
they've in essence had something
choreographed duck-duck-goose I think I
was one of them came out after it
doesn't one of them wasn't my favorite
one but it was one of why would you know
they're better than that I think okay
they've had a lot of good ones though
it's been it's super entertaining people
stay to the end of the game and they
have fun with it so you know our fans
have fun whether they have fun with it
and I don't be aware of this Brockman
cuz you know this might not have pierced
your bubble while you were flying here
to Indianapolis yesterday but Don Cherry
the longtime sure
Hockey Night in Canada announcer called
the the storm surges it's called and the
players a bunch of jerks so after the
Tuesday pounding of the Los Angeles
Kings by the final score of six to one I
believe the final score right that's a
good game they they had the players come
out and throw out t-shirts to the fans
with the words of the projection onto
the ice bunch of jerks I'm looking at
the video right now it's fantastic so
that was the first time I got involved
because they were gonna they had their
thing they were gonna do and I never
knew what it was ever and I I heard what
they were gonna do because I think they
needed the shirts so I had to pretty so
I I had the projector put it but what's
on the shirts and we I your idea
I finally got involved so but other than
that no I didn't I that was the first
time even knew what they were doing in
advance and maybe they don't want to
jinx themselves right because you have
ideas and then and then if you lose but
by the way one by five goals which is a
rarity obviously there and then you and
then it's very rare to see the words
bunch of jerks being projected onto the
ice I know I haven't worn the shirt or
the hat or anything just because yeah
it's a little I'm not sure I could do
that right it's massive the projection
is half the ice
it's enormous it would be a dystonia
have you heard from any fellow owners
and they mean show like what are you
doing I haven't no I haven't that Minh
was in town
Tuesday he said he was there and watched
it yeah he was he was physically there
for the bunch of jerks projection onto
the yes he was in the suite he won't
leave early so you know it's six to one
like Gary you've been here all day don't
you want to get moving his I stayed at
the end of every game one eight six one
I'm about to leave so or you knew bunch
of jerks is about to be put on the ice
as well I she wanted the commissioner
out I mean no he's on he he asked the
players that morning in the locker room
I think he there's probably a small part
of him that just wanted to make sure
that they were good with her right he I
told him and as I've told this story I'm
their hundred this is their deal we
would I wouldn't ask them to do that or
prompt them to do it and and so he was
pretty comfortable when he started here
in their ideas and they kind of have fun
with it so now it's it's just something
fun that we do or they do and I get the
benefit of it there you go
Tom dungeon who is the principal owner
and governor of the Carolina Hurricanes
and now the chairman of the Alliance of
American football here on the Rich Eisen
show in Indianapolis
why are you here on behalf of the AF is
that why you're here at the comma yes
okay and what are you doing on behalf of
the AAF at the comma whatever they tell
me to do we've got some different
meetings set up and getting people and
and just trying to learn you know how
can we help okay
why did you want to get involved with
the AF I didn't I didn't know I did
anyway I was i I had heard about the
league and and didn't think you know the
risk profile of a start-up football
league isn't something I would consider
normally or I didn't and so I didn't
participate when they were out in the
world looking for partners and you know
after week one football looked really
good the ratings were good my kids were
interested I actually watched didn't
know I wanted to and enjoyed it how old
are your kids 17 and 15 the boys and you
know fantasy football's a thing that's
pretty important in their lives right
and matter of fact they make fun of me
sometimes on the hockey team like you
know like you could buy a football team
so
so Wow no set up by a league kids yeah
jet rolls okay I showed them and so so
anyway I I was at a breakfast on
Wednesday morning with one of my
partners I'm involved in business called
top golf and he said you should call
I've heard of that it's good one fan so
you should call Charlie ever salt
because he knows the way I like to do
things is if there's a little less risk
and a good opportunity at the same time
which is hard to find and they had put
up good ratings the football looked good
and they're in a position where instead
of having to continue to raise money
they they could have used the stability
that I was able to provide them and so
within 24 hours we had a deal done where
you know I took control the league in
the sense of you know I'll put up the
money and I get to make the decisions
and make sure that this thing is done
continue to build on what they've done
and then hopefully they went really fast
right so now we got to go make sure we
put the foundation around everything
they've done so let me take this one
step at a time here Tom aaf comes on the
air on CBS weekend after the Super Bowl
you're just sitting there watching it
with your two kids or you just you you
flip upon it or whatever sitting there
right there you had no idea you were
gonna commit a quarter of a billion
dollars to that league two weeks later
animal none Wednesday morning at
breakfast after the first game was the
first time even heard anything about it
and by Thursday afternoon you were
committed done have you ever done a
business deal like that and you're
entirely know what what I did was I put
up some money that weekend but I
wouldn't let him use my name okay and I
wanted to make sure that if I decided
against it after I spent the next four
days on the phone with different people
and it kept getting better I got better
and better reviews as opposed to
normally it gets worse right when you
everybody tells you the best stuff and
so we I started to feel better and
better I went to the game in San Antonio
and I wanted to see the rating so once I
put my name on this we're gonna make
this work right this is what I'm
committed to
doing so I had I had a period of time so
it sounds crazy to do 24 hours back sad
five days sure so it's way better
understood yeah and two weeks of ratings
right so now I saw that people kept
watching right and and they didn't just
get lucky so what is your vision for
this then Tom you know our I think the
plan is just to be a Development League
the whole story of giving people a
chance I think I'm not sure if you
graduate in college and became a sports
broadcaster you could accomplish the
same success again I'm sure I couldn't
do what I did if I live my life over a
lot of times and so the idea of creating
something or being part of something
where people get a chance
and whether it's coaches players refs
where maybe innovate technology
broadcasters that's I think that's
compelling it's interesting and so if we
can just be a Developmental League then
serves the NFL I think that's
interesting and I think it's compelling
and so that's that's what I like about
it well it's definitely come I mean I
talked to we had Charlie in studio last
Friday where I loved listening in on the
replay conversation I can't wait til
somebody actually goes for it on fourth
and 12 to try and get the home yeah you
know instead I like that idea instead of
an onside kick
I like seeing a bunch of guys who I've
seen before you know there's some name
recognition right as well I do I do like
all I love the coaches I mean Spurrier
obviously hung on it is it is it is a
lot of fun can you make money on this
don't you think
look it's not it's not yes you can you
can be successful here it's not the NFL
it's not gonna be that type success
right but you know if you think about it
as development or minor leagues it'll be
the best of that genre for sure
so because it's football and the NFL
does such a good job that they create
that halo and and that opportunity so
yeah I don't think this isn't gonna be
that difficult to get it to a point
it'll be a lot of hard work so I don't
want to minimize what everybody's going
but the risk reward of this investment
is not that scary now that people are
watching and people like it how did you
make your mind suppose you might not
know I had
a finance company mostly did auto loans
and then you know I was lucky along the
way that did some good you know did some
different investments that worked out
you know one of them one of which was
top golf and yeah I've just been very
fortunate very very very fortunate
what's your game do you play tell you
what Golf okay come on now well I mean
I'm not asking for strokes here but I
mean IBM Lenore we knows how to play
golf we're in the deep end of the pool
yes yes we are okay what it was Evan
what are you not 10 to 15 we need at
least 10 at least 10 strokes I'll do
that
I also know I'd probably race you too
for what I see well now hose the thing
hey that's me alright you look live you
look like one of those in shape
billionaires to me okay
I am neither but I'm willing to do
something for chat for st. you know
something for st. you here's the problem
yeah I don't want to look bad like I
don't care about look maybe maybe ping
pong or something where people can see
how enough oh wow all I'm saying is that
I'm raising money for charity while
you're throwing around a quarter of a
billion dollars you know over 24 hours
he allowed a period I'm willing together
well at while it's open I'm ready I got
to come up with the idea though okay
let's do it maybe at this championship
game in Vegas we'll come up with
something I like it that's in about six
weeks time right yes Vegas yeah whatever
you come up with I'll do it okay if
you'll do it
I got a I've got a I think we can be
there I've got four to six weeks to
figure this thing out it's her
profession I do like it one last
question for you on the AAF did they
need your money I mean the conversations
you are a savior yeah I think Charlie I
think Charlie had many people he was
talking to and he's pretty resourceful
he got this far I think he would have
been fine it would have just been a lot
more difficult to continue down that
path versus mmm it's over now like we
have to talk about the money anymore we
just have to talk about continuing to
build the league and grow it and and so
you know what's nice
is all his energy has turned towards
what's important right put on really
good football games and get people an
opportunity to make it in the NFL and so
that was I think why they did it with me
because obviously giving up control was
something that I had to have and he had
to give and so he had choices but right
but maybe maybe this was a better one I
hope well he's a good dude man I've
millions I've known him for years
obviously he's from rare stock you know
his mom and dad are two very successful
awesome people on the planet they've
imbued that in him the only thing that I
have a problem with Charlie's he's Notre
Dame it's a big problem for me talks
about a lot too Rudy that golden dome as
soon as we land I came here all time
when I took Notre Dame well that's right
yeah I agree he's pretty good girl where
did you go
SMU SMU yeah okay okay close to home
Cowboys fan you're excited about Witten
yeah I'm real excited I I think he's one
of the best human beings oh he he's an
unbelievable guy he is I'm happy for him
and aces first bet he's a first-ballot
hall-of-famer any first-ballot human
being I do love that guy
and he's still in shape like he he's
like a brick he's like a wall I believe
he's common do you want to hear his
statement please quote from Jason Witten
the fire inside of me to compete and
play this game is burning too strong
this team is a great group of rising
young stars and I want to help them make
a run at a championship this was
completely my decision and I'm very
comfortable with it looking forward to
getting back in the dirt awesome he's
the best can you imagine though I mean
him sit now with Jerry how long that
took Jerry - oh my gosh
by the way I've got a great before I let
you go I've got a great fantasy team
name for you tell me a bunch of jerks I
like it
bunch of jerks okay I mean then uni and
Dom Shari is the avatar
just go for it man I'm with it we're
doing it we're they like my folks as
soon as I came out they send me a shirt
we got to sell this shirt okay bunch of
folks can go I should have brought you
on tape I'll send you in please thank
you and on behalf of all the phone
who were up at the worldwide leader in
sports as long as I was at in Bristol
Connecticut I really do appreciate you
give a little Hartford Whaler love
that's good yeah I mean that you gave a
little bit of a nod to where the
Hurricanes came from I thought that was
really cool yeah and it looks really
good
hi my where my Hartford Whaler t-shirt
notice people know I mean I swear to you
they will stop and say I love that team
it's the best yeah I love it we're
actually we play in Boston here in March
and we're wearing it there since its
March sometimes in March but you're not
gonna go so far as to have an arena in a
mall like they did that were they had it
oh my god Tom I'll never forget when I
first got to ESPN and a buddy mine says
hey you want to go to a whaler game that
I I'm like yeah absolutely
I honestly I'd never in a well again
before my entire life and they tell me
it's in the mall what are you talking
about in the mall in the mall in the
Hartford mall just like the same way
that you'd walk into a movie theater is
it there anymore I don't think I I know
they played me really colicky and
Hartford so I don't know am I really
that place has been my rearview mirror
for 16 years now so you live now Los
Angeles no Los Angeles California
well yeah Tom great to meet you nice to
meet you you bet No No thank you for
coming on congrats on what's going on
with your hockey team and obviously with
the AAF thanks for thanks for being here
thank you that's Tom Darden right here
on the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience